POW weld is the sequel to 2017 it adapt
Stephen King's classic novel while tying
up all the loose ends from the first
installment let's roll up our sleeves
wade into the sewers and dig into the
details of how the saga ends this is the
ending of it chapter 2 explained and
before you open the door labeled very
scary be warned
spoilers await you Stephen King's novel
it isn't just the story of a creepy
clown terrorizing some kids and then
returning to do it all over again when
they're adults there's a whole cosmology
to the saga which includes a giant
godlike turtle that coughed up the known
universe when it had a tummy ache aside
from a few subtle nods here and there
the movies mostly sidestepped the
ancient interdimensional mythology of
the book but one element does show up in
it chapter 2 the true form of it when he
goes to visit the shook opy tribe and
takes one of their vision granting
concoctions mike learns that it came to
earth in a meteor strike that left a
crater in derry and is made up of dead
lights mostly orange but sometimes blue
spheres of light of immense power though
lights can be seen in brief moments in
the first film
it appears entirely as dead light as
chapter 2 reaches its climax and even
after taking on other forms the dead
lights are still visibly powering the
creature becoming increasingly weaker as
the losers literally bring it down to
size its true form is revealed because
the losers perform the ritual of chud a
ceremony that differs pretty wildly in
the movie from the way it works in the
book the movies take on the ritual
involves each member of the club burning
a token of his or her childhood and
reciting a chant to make the dead lights
turn dark then trapping the dead lights
inside a pyramid shaped relic Mike stole
the ritual is the key to defeating it in
the book though it takes two tries 27
years apart but the losers attempt
essentially fails in the movie at least
at first that's because it's revealed
Mike lied to everyone in an attempt to
simply bring them all back together the
ritual wasn't successful before when the
Native Americans tried to do it and it
doesn't kill it when the losers try this
time either
at least not until they've gone through
the ringer just a little bit more so
they can truly overcome the fears that
feed it Ritchie
isn't exactly a tough nut to crack hi
rich what are you afraid of
comes his token for the ritual of chud
is a literal token from the local arcade
and as is so often the case in the
transition from childhood to adulthood
his fear has morphed into anxiety the
adult Ricci throws up twice in it
chapter 2 and threatens to leave Derry
several times because he just can't
stand the idea of losing what he's
gained as a famous stand-up comedian
Ritchie spends the first half of chapter
two mercilessly needling his childhood
pal Eddie and he doesn't hesitate to
call Stanley the weakest of the losers
when he finds out about Stanley killing
himself he can be mean and has a hard
time expressing his real feelings
Ritchie has to visit the synagogue where
Stanley had a disastrous Bar Mitzvah and
more significantly come to openly care
about the well-being of his closest
friend Eddie whom he finally can admit
he loves to overcome his self-absorption
and play a part in defeating it for
Eddie's part the fear he has to overcome
is also a sort of self obsession his
hypochondria and fear of bodily harm are
paralyzing they hamper him from taking
action both as a child and as an adult
like when he's confronted with Stanley's
bug-like severed head for trying to
rescue his mother from the leper he
keeps seeing it as it isn't until he
gives up one of his gazebos his
malapropism for placebo in the form of
his inhaler for his token and comes to
believe in the monster killing power of
a makeshift spear fashioned from a metal
fence post that he can work up the
courage to mount a full frontal attack
on it weakening the monster before the
rest of the losers can deal their final
psychological blows Eddie is fatally
impaled but in the service of saving his
friends after a lifetime of being frozen
with fear his final act is one of
bravery even nearly 30 years after his
brother Georgie's death bill is still
plagued by guilt and feelings of
responsibility he finds himself shouting
down a storm drain just like he did in
his youth and he conveniently gets
Georgie's paper boat back from Pennywise
to use as his token in the ritual he
fears not being able to save the people
around him eventually he tries
Gill's to save another young dairy boy
from suffering a fate similar to
Georgie's at the end of penny wises
teeth it takes a full on envisioned
confrontation with his younger self
during the final showdown with it for
build to come to terms with what
happened and absolve himself of blame
telling himself that he was in fact a
good older brother with that resolved he
could help destroy it and maybe finally
write a decent ending to his next novel
though Ben has grown from a chubby
bullied kid into a handsome successful
man he still clearly feels ostracized he
notably keeps himself at a remove from
his coworkers at his architecture firm
video conferencing in from his massive
empty house meanwhile Beverly is in an
abusive marriage that mirrors her
relationship with her father when she
returns to her childhood home its
unfamiliar and inhabited by a woman who
turns into a rampaging unclothed monster
nowhere really feels like home to her
after some amnesia based uncertainty
about who really loved whom on Beverly's
part Beverly and Ben finally find the
linchpins to work through their fears
each other
Beverly brings the postcard with the
poem Ben wrote for her to the ritual of
cut and Ben brings the yearbook page Bev
and no one else signed as Ben is made to
think he's being buried alive in the
losers secret hideout and Bev finds
herself drowning in blood in the
bathroom stall where she was tormented
by bullies they reach out to each other
and break free of its spell much like
his parents found themselves trapped as
a raging fire killed them Mike has
trapped himself in Derry while everyone
else left and forgot all about what
happened there in 1989 by the way that
he's here it all gets with me and I've
left
so yeah I knew wrong he has appointed
himself the chronicler and expert on all
things it convening with the Shakopee WA
in hopes of unleashing ancient secrets
in time for the returning losers to
defeat the creature and it works just
not the way he originally suspected more
than the ritual of chud one little
proverb about living things having to
abide by the rules of the shape they
inhabit ends up being the key to taking
down penny wise when Mike remembers that
detail he sets off a chain of events
that leads all the other losers to bring
the monster down to size with their
words calling it's little more than a
clown their name-calling shrinks
Pennywise down so small that they can
easily pull out his still-beating heart
and destroy it Mike thrives as someone
who rallies his friends as signified by
the way he brings a rock Beverly threw
at the town bullies as his token a major
difference from the book's ending is
that all the movie losers leave Derry
with the memories of their encounter
with it intact but to everyone's
surprise without the literal scars from
when they cut their hands to signify
their blood bond at the end of the first
movie
the pain is exorcised bill writes a book
that's very similar to Stephen King's it
Ben and Beverly go on boat excursions
together having finally found true
companionship Richie finishes carving
his and Eddie's initials into a fence
finally revealing how much he cares
Mike leaves town at last and everyone
receives a letter from Stanley written
before he killed himself in the letter
Stanley gives a rationale for his
decision to kill himself not to escape
facing down it but to prevent his
friends from dying because he wasn't
sure he could take another round with
the creature he knew if the losers
weren't unified they'd all die when the
adult losers look in a shop window and
see the reflections of the younger
selves Stanley's there I never felt like
a loser Lewis are you check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]